durban is a thriving modern city  in kwazulu-natal home of the sulu nation  its people live a fast-paced 21st  century life  yet many of them carry their traditions  deep within them  i find that the traditional zulu attire  is so regal looking  just the colors and the vibrancy just  beautiful  i traveled out of dublin to discover the  zulu way of life  i didn't realize how close the city is  to the beautiful rolling hills of  heartland  i was excited to find people still  living according to a proud passionate  heritage  not just respecting the old ways but  celebrating tradition  joyously i found people with an amazing  zest for life  flashes of color everywhere i was swept  up in the drama the noise the excitement  of it all i mean every photographer  lives for those moments  it's something i'll never forget